today's one minute monday is don't
settle too often in business and in life
we settle we settle for okay employees
we settle for okay business ideas we
settle for okay
life partners and when you settle
you're you're giving up on something
great for something okay
so here's an example i'm moving and i
love this building i wanted to get in
this building so badly
i love the location i love the layout
and i found this perfect unit for me
and i went to negotiate with the person
who owned it because i wanted to rent
there for
a year before living and
and he said because i was an
entrepreneur i was very sketchy
and he demanded all sorts of different
concessions like paying extra months
rent and a few extra things
and i found that hilarious but i love
the unit so much
like okay i'm gonna negotiate i'm gonna
get it down and and we got to the day
where
everything was agreed on all i had to do
was sign on the dotted line
and i walked away i walked away because
it didn't feel right because
because i felt like i was settling
because i'd have to work with this guy
for at least
a year together and how could i being
the entrepreneur guy
work with somebody who doesn't believe
in entrepreneurs and thinks i'm sketchy
because of it right it's not right and
so i walked away and you need to do the
same thing
in your life in your business when
something doesn't feel right when you
feel like you're settling
have the courage and confidence to walk
away from it
because something great is around the
corner
belief
hi raquel english here with mermaid
junkie tv are you on
evan's newsletter subscription if not
you should be i read every single one
and you should too ciao
you